la comisión europea espera la decisión
final de los estados son miembros de la
unión europea sobre el sexto paquete de
sanciones contra rusia en el que el veto
al petróleo es la principal carta la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der layen propuso a los gobiernos
europeos imponer un embargo total al
crudo ruso planteando un periodo de
transición hasta final de este año para
así contener el golpe en los mercados y
también preparar todas las vías de
alternativas de suministro algo que
hungría eslovaquia y república checa-
ven demasiado precipitado las nuevas
sanciones además de vetar el petróleo
contemplan medidas contra los
responsables de los ataques abusa y
mariupol y también plantea expulsar del
sistema de transferencias interbancarias
internacionales swift al banco más
grande de rusia hablamos del sever banca
para ello entonces para ver lo que
estaba ocurriendo y qué va a pasar con
este sexto paquete de sanciones quiero
saludar a rózsa net y barrios ella es
analista independiente de energía
también consejera fundadora de voz
experta gracias rosane ti por estar con
nosotros directo américa de france24 le
pregunto qué significará este metal
petróleo ruso para los países de europa
claro buenos días muchas gracias por su
invitación la decisión es una decisión
compleja ese lugar a la duda para una
región que tiene una dependencia
importantísima del petróleo como como se
explicaba ya previamente y hay ahí
preocupaciones particulares de los
países más dependientes
fundamentalmente y esto hay que
entenderlo bien fundamentalmente pór y
vamos a decirlo así el tiempo que tienen
para adaptarse llama la atención es
clarísimo que nadie se opone a esta
prohibición pero si hay una preocupación
por la velocidad en que se pueda hacer
toda vez que no es esta está claro está
lo está esta guerra nos ha sorprendido a
todos y por el momento resulta muy
complicado pensar en poder abandonar lo
pongo así de un día para otro el
suministro de rusia por parte de europa
esto sin embargo digamos es una clara
señal de que las
las sanciones a rusia van a continuar
escalando es un hecho por ejemplo que
queda pendiente la decisión y no se ha
avisado nada aún sobre el gas natural en
gas natural la dependencia todavía es
mayor porque hay una dificultad
insisto más grande para poderse
suministrar
entonces que significa significar una
señal clara de continuar adelante
penalizando a rusia pero sin duda es una
medida vamos a decirlo así dolorosa que
mantiene los precios de los
hidrocarburos
muy cerca de los 110 particularmente el
petróleo de los 110 dólares por barril y
por ejemplo otro elemento importante es
que ya se llevó a cabo la reunión
ministerial de la opep en donde la opep
simplemente anuncia que va a continuar
con un programa vamos a decir normal
normal si digamos eliminando los efectos
de la invasión rusa aumentando sobre 430
mil barriles diarios su producción
dice que encuentra un mercado balanceado
es decir para lópez por lo menos en el
papel no hay ningún elemento no incluye
no menciona el problema que se tiene
conducida por lo tanto el pensar que se
puede aumentar la oferta para sustituir
la producción rusa es muy complicado y
porque digamos razones de europa nuestra
lista para poder enfrentar este veto
porque los países realmente no se
terminan de poner de acuerdo
bueno las condiciones de seguridad
energética no se pueden construir de la
noche a la mañana podríamos decir que
fue una decisión histórica de estos
países de mantener la dependencia del
suministro ruso por razones digamos
particulares a cada país no se tomaron
medidas
décadas antes pues para ir
diversificando
el suministro y en
considerar digamos no solamente por una
invasión sino por cualquier otra razón
que la dependencia de un solo país es un
es representa un riesgo importante lo
digo con toda certeza ya que méxico
tiene una situación idéntica digamos en
términos de la dependencia que tenemos
del suministro del gas de los eeuu de
américa entonces que requiere esto
además de una capacidad de producción
digamos para todo el planeta para
atender está sustituir 5 millones de
barriles diarios de petróleo que ahora
que ofrece rusia a europa
representa un esfuerzo para todos los
países productores por un lado y además
requiere del desarrollo de
infraestructura que permita recibir ese
ese producto
a lo largo del continente y los
desarrollos de infraestructura
requieren de varios años para poder
estar listos para operar ahora roxana ti
como se puede entonces abastecer la
unión europea si corta por completo el
suministro de energía hablamos de
petróleo de gas desde rusia claro
definitivamente es una medida que no
desde un punto de vista es imposible de
implementar de un día para otro
particularmente en gas aún cuando la
señal ha sido clara de digamos de
cambiar de manera estructurada el
suministro desde rusia y los eeuu están
incrementando su capacidad de
exportación y los precios son muy
atractivos como para que otros países
como qatar australia también aprovechen
esta oportunidad
definitivamente insisto la dependencia
es excesiva estamos hablando de un 5 por
ciento de toda la producción global el
pretender es lo que es lo que rusia
aporta europa y definitivamente el mundo
no está listo en este momento para
pensar que pudiera incrementar en 5 por
ciento toda su producción global esto
tiene un problema digamos que se va a ir
haciendo
más apremiante conforme
regresemos al otoño y el invierno ya que
es ahí donde europa sin duda se ve en
condiciones de muchísima fragilidad para
atender su demanda doméstica claro le
pregunto entonces razones de ti ante
todo esto que tanto funcionan estas
sanciones contra rusia porque como ya lo
vemos tienen muchísimas consecuencias
negativas para los países que las
imponen claro yo diría que las sanciones
son necesarias
digamos en términos de una señal y vamos
a decirlo así geopolítica
pero la verdad y esto pues vamos
seguramente está haciendo perfectamente
valorado por todos los líderes políticos
del mundo es que su implementación es
compleja entonces quiero insistir en que
esta decisión es posible de implementar
pero no a la velocidad que se está
buscando y si sin embargo la señal que
nos queda a todo el planeta tierra es la
importancia de desarrollar condiciones
máximas de seguridad
energética y esto qué quiere decir en
principio una diversificación adecuada